I'm home!
What's this?
Naoko, welcome home.
Where's the food?
I tried to make a stew, but...
I gave up.
Seriously?
The water is perfect.
Why don't we have frog soup for dinner?
Just kidding.
Dad, you fool!
It's Mom's birthday today!
I wanted to make her happy
by throwing a surprise party!
Ouch! Hot, hot!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
I'm sorry I destroyed the house.
It's not Naoko's fault.
It's mine. I'm such a hopeless man--
I mean, frog...
What a surprise party!
Who'd have thought our house
would blow up! That was a total surprise!
Here's your present.
Well, it was...
Wow! What a lovely hair ornament.
Honey, we're having frog soup for dinner.
That sounds good.
Thank you, Naoko, sweetheart.
No way!